delicious
delicious
happy friday my friday friends
so china's president is pissed off
and not because lebron james is a lousy
kisser
[Laughter]
because nancy pelosi the spork with
eyebrows
[Laughter]
took a girls shopping trip to taiwan
china said scores of planes to the
taiwan strait never met him
and fired live missiles near the
self-ruled island
to be fair they warned her but she said
she didn't hear them because she forgot
to charge the batteries in her miracle
ear
the u.s military brass responded
immediately mobilizing troops for an
emergency pronouns workshop
[Laughter]
so china fired a load of missiles and
waters off taiwan activated 100 planes
including fighter jets and bombers plus
10 warships
but man don't they know how bad all that
is for the environment
so how's the media handling this well
imagine a country issues a warning
telling you that what you're about to do
crosses the line and yet you do it
anyway you know it's like when my wife
tells me to stop leaving my shoes and
socks on the floor
in larry kudlow's pool house
tired of the lies china says don't go to
taiwan but hey screw you tai china we're
coming over just for
and giggles
which are the secret services nicknames
for biden and harris
disgusting
and so like a divorce lawyer you drive
up tensions between adversaries while
also driving one enemy china into the
arms of another russia
warships planes missiles all that's
missing is this
[Music]
that was actually nancy pelosi doing
some window shopping in taipei
poor taiwan threatened by chinese
battleships and old battle axes
still you gotta wonder what nancy's
husband is doing right now
[Applause]
but the revenge has only just begun
this is one expensive shopping trip from
the get-go it already cost the taxpayers
millions including the taxpayers and
pelosi's disgusting district san
francisco which as you know looks like
this
yeah she's got her priorities straight
and the fact is she didn't need to fly
her eyebrows are already in the mile
high club
looks like someone just showed her my
ratings
so nan goes out of her way to take chyna
off after telling everyone else not to
do the very same thing i'd call her
two-faced but that's five faces ago
so what kind of leader would do
something so stupid beside the current
prez who needs training wheels for a
stationary bike
well we were always told it would be
this guy who would cause global unrest
the trump administration's reckless rash
decisions are no substitute for real
global leadership multiple national
security crises all exacerbated by
donald trump's erratic and untethered
foreign policy impulses what you need to
do is lower the temperature and not
increase the temperature and in a way i
think you could say that he's playing
right into kim's
hands so it's the erratic nature of this
which i don't think is strategic which
leads me to believe that trump isn't
serious they may not be up to the job a
man you can bait with a tweet is not a
man we can trust with nuclear weapons
she looks so much healthier before she
killed jeffrey epstein
but seriously
where is joe when it comes to china what
the hell joe
oh no no look look i i i can't tell that
lady what to do i didn't want her to go
but the uh if you ever try to tell an
old lady what to do they'd do the
opposite so i said go ahead go to taiwan
i don't care
i'm a little afraid of her anyway
i'm more afraid of nancy than the
chinese
i mean did you see when she ripped up
that state of the union address
come on i said uh that's one dizzy broad
you stay out of her way joe
dizzy broad can i say that no probably
not they're gonna put me back in the
basement
so
trump was the danger i don't think so
unlike pelosi he didn't go to an
adversary to stick a thumb in their eye
he went there you know to see what
happens
i want to see what happens we're in very
close contact
we have come certainly a long way at
least rhetorically
with north korea but we'll see what
happens that would be a great thing for
the world
great thing for the world so we'll see
how it all comes about we'll see what
happens we're going to see what happens
we're going to see what happens we're
going to see what happens
so using basic sales techniques trump
removed america's number one threat off
the table even according to obama and it
wasn't michelle's meatloaf it was north
korea and he did it without risking one
troop's life meanwhile we've seen the
chaos that's happened since china mobile
mobilizing against taiwan russia
invading ukraine will smith making the
oscars watchable
[Laughter]
i mean how about the middle east if
anyone else did the abraham accords you
know anyone else being a democrat they
would have received the nobel peace
prize or at least a happy ending from
jerry nadler
fact is trump has been the most anti-war
president in recent history under him
fewer people died while terrorists were
looking over their shoulders like r
kelly in the prison showers
[Music]
meanwhile it's the dems who are the
dopes creating global instability
but consider how the media might handle
this latest provocation if trump had
done it
but you'll never know because trump
never would have done that he understood
the cost of things and he understood
leverage which pelosi just handed to the
chinese fact is we forget what trump was
accused of doing because the actual
doing never happened and the accusers
are fulfilling the very things they
accused him of doing
under trump no wars and just peaceful
accords and handshakes under biden hot
wars cold wars storage wars cupcake wars
but you know thank god we got rid of
those tweets right huh now we can all
sleep the sleep of angels knowing his
tweets are no longer out there wandering
the cosmos looking to hurt someone's
feelings anymore
you know like this one quote every time
i speak of the haters and losers i do so
with great love and affection
they cannot help the fact that they were
born up
they still hit
they still hit
i'm assuming that's real
how about this one sorry losers and
haters but my iq is one of the highest
and you all know it please don't feel so
stupid or insecure it's not your fault
and uh
perhaps the one that started it all this
is when some guy tweets at trump if you
hate america so much you should run for
president and fix things
trump tweets back be careful
so that was a bigger threat than
anything we ever knew
so we kicked him out replaced him with
an idiot who doesn't even know he's
doing these bad things until he watches
the local news and finds out the same
way we do
suddenly we have wars divisiveness
inflation a missing president all at
once
and we have nancy to thank for the
latest chaos it's amazing she can do her
job with a straight face
[Laughter]
not really
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when she talks ben shapiro asks her to
slow down outnumbered co-host emily
cabano
he's one of our favorite faces and gets
all the best parking spaces
retired marine corps
he's the only doc who has you wait while
he gets undressed oh sometimes you have
her
dr drew
not true by the way the only thing this
chick smokes is her competition fox news
contributor cat tip
emily how are you so good oh that's
great so joey
that was a joke it's friday
what do you make of the trip did
anything positive come out of this trip
not that i know of so far and you you
nailed it in your monologue when you
said you know that trump understood
costs and here we have the speaker that
said the purpose of that visit she said
was to not disrupt the status quo in
fact to preserve it she said we will not
stand by and let china isolate taiwan
since she's been in the five seconds
since
china has unleashed hell on taiwan
drones military drills with icbms the
first in history that went over their
land import bans in interrupting their
328 billion trade agreement in the first
day alone they stopped 100 ships from
leaving taiwan
cyber attacks drones and then they
summoned the u.s ambassador to china and
said to his face we're going to make you
pay the price so it's sort of similar to
when a human finds like a you know half
dead animal or a butterfly or but oh i'm
gonna save this and then they crush it
accidentally that is exact
or that or you put it on joey's wall but
that's that's exactly what pelosi has
done so i think through her arrogance
and her maintaining oh we're here to
preserve everything meanwhile as she's
walking with a fixed expression to the
plane taiwan is in flames behind her and
to your point i have yet to see
something positive come out of it but
not to be a debbie downer i don't expect
that anything will
all right that was debbie downer joey uh
what's worse uh colin kovid the china
virus or inciting world war iii
with a shopping trip to taiwan
i think it's a loaded question you know
it depends on who you are and what your
world is if you're if you're a liberal i
mean colin kova the china virus is
really bad
i mean it really it really it incites
violence on somebody nobody's proven yet
but somebody yeah i think one of the
funniest things about this is like china
slaps nancy pelosi with sanctions yes
like i mean johnny couldn't sanction me
my idea of investing money is buying a
pickup truck right like if china wanted
sex to me they have to hack into my
amazon account yes like you know so if
our congress is uh bought into china
sanctuary i don't care yeah well yeah
that's true sanctioning nancy pelosi
she's rich enough to so that matt they
can do that right yeah she's got she's
you know i'm not saying she's done
anything wrong because i'm a capitalist
but you know she's been a public servant
for 80 years and she's got enough money
she's invested in huawei or something i
mean come on yeah they also sanctioned
her husband by the way they sanctioned
her immediate family members too which
means he got in more trouble from china
for being her husband than he did in
california for getting in oh that's
dr drew what do you make of all this
isn't it funny this weird projection
it's like a reverse projection all of
these things that were supposed to
happen under trump are happening under
japan that seems to be the primary
psychological process that goes on which
is people have their own internal sort
of
feelings that they disavow and they
project them on to everybody else and
then they end up acting them out and
that's exactly what we're seeing here
you know it's so funny my wife turned to
me to tell you she goes why didn't
what's his name go like the president
and then she goes and she goes then she
goes is he dead
i can see your wife ask that question
i was like wow we're there
he did have a weekend at barney's look
today with the glasses on yeah she was
literally very serious was quite
concerned
yeah yeah
i think um it's there's an ulterior
motive here with nancy like like uh
eight she's in her 80s now it's like
what a great way to go out she would
have done this when she was 35 but if
you know i don't understand it i can't
understand what she's doing i hope it
doesn't cause any serious problems
but it i what what was she thinking what
was she trying to get out of it i can't
figure it out maybe distract from the
husband he's got a lot of problems the
best thing about this cat is that it
like
she can never criticize republicans of
being anti-climate because not only was
the was the flight you know obviously
burning fuel but china now pulls out of
every climate agreement and everything
why aren't they freaked out about yeah
yeah it's like now china goes like hey
we don't have to do that anymore so she
just basically screwed the planet well
but why isn't her constituency
absolutely apoplectic about that this is
the biggest source of this problem yeah
they're they're back in business
constituency is half rich people half
homeless
or if you're you know uh well never mind
let's say something disgusting catboy oh
that'd be so unlikely
[Laughter]
is there anything good from this well
for her for a little bit for about five
minutes she had a lot of people even on
both sides of the aisle saying yeah
nancy that's true way to go that i was
not one of those people and i'm not one
of those people now but for a little bit
she was not in the headlines for her
husband's really good guessing on
investments or for his you know booze
and pills filled joyride gone awry
uh and but that's the only thing it did
i get that the chinese communist party
is awful i get that a invasion of taiwan
would be terrible but what she did
actually made that more likely not less
likely and she got to have all these
people tell her she was so brave and so
cool and take the pictures and then
leave and be out of there and have it
all go
exactly yeah it's crazy it is crazy and
you know
uh
you're right about like the republicans
yeah people were yeah they were except
for two which was really interesting the
two people who hate each other mitt
romney and donald trump both said this
was a bad idea so when you have two
people that hate each other yeah yep
because agree because people argue for
things like this by saying okay that you
know the chinese communist party is bad
but i care more about results especially
when we're talking about the possibility
of a world war yeah what did you
actually do to help anyone you actually
make things work hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else